this this whole thing is spreading let's
talk about the the stepmom oh yeah dude
so we got it we got another article here
yeah sure here yeah put up stepmother of
the Atlanta cop charge was shooting Dade
ratio and Brooks is fired for her job as
a mortgage company's HR director because
of employees creating a hostile working
environment so her employees are
creating the hostile work environment
let's read about it you know I think she
did what I think she defended her son
yeah probably
and they were like how dare you how dare
yet that fend your son yeah make sense
to me yeah that would be controversy uh
and see uh
Garrett Rolf stepmother Melissa Ralph
had her employment at the Atlanta based
equity prime mortgage terminated this
week the company said Melissa and HR
director had violated company policy and
created an uncomfortable and hostile
working environment they said the
violations came as Melissa was
transitioning to a leave of absence
granted by the firm it is not clear what
Melissa said or did to warrant her
firing Melissa apparently wrote to
Georgia congressional candidate Marjorie
Taylor Green calling what is happening
to her cepsa and nonsense
news of Melissa's firing came just hours
after Ralph was taking into custody
after being charged with felony murder
over Brookes death over a week ago the
sins of the father this is what they do
in authoritarian and communists freedom
of speech is dying right in front of our
eyes it's not dead we're still here
right now yep this would have been shut
off if it was dead people don't want us
talking like this no I think freedom of
speech has it's dying it's not dead yet
I think it is dead
okay can you can you say are there
things you can say right now that would
result in this video being taken down
yep I mean we're on we've talked about
social media we we talked about it you
we can't say certain words and you're
like I don't say those words you can't
say someone's name so you you know it's
not bending the knee but it's tilting
slightly towards YouTube it's the same
thing so you know there's it what's the
difference in in my circumstance
there's not much I could say that would
get me banned because my opinions are
rather moderate okay there are opinions
you can have that you'll be banned for
instantly and yet there's words you know
you you know you can't insult veterans
on YouTube really you can't insult
veterans huh what do you mean how do you
mean like insult them you can't look the
same at a speech they call them a name
yeah yeah or you know if you were to say
something negative about veterans you
tube will strike your channel Wow
you can't criticize someone for their
immigration status okay there's no free
speech free speech would be now now we
recognized on to the Supreme Court there
are limits to speech and I believe it's
fair to say like telling someone to go
do something and then they go commit a
crime and yeah yeah incitement is a
limit expressing your political belief
beliefs no matter how detestable is free
speech yeah YouTube isn't allowed that
so if you put it this way if free speech
is a range of opinions from negative 10
to positive 10 and you're only allowed
negative 10 to positive 2 it's not free
speech that's true entire quadrant has
been purged from YouTube someone in the
comments said it's on life support
yes yeah yeah that's pretty accurate
it's it's it's kind of like you know
where it were it's a scene from Star
Wars where the rooms closing in hush
them and we're like the trash compactors
and right now we've got the beam like
stopping it from crushing us for the
time being we just need we need r2d2 to
turn turn it off yeah but we don't have
it on r2d2 where are you somebody turn
the trash compactor roughly it's it's
not so much about free speech in this
story even I think the free speech were
granted right now is IIIi think this I
think
fridges is completely dead and what's
happening is YouTube allows us to do
this to make sure there's an
overreaction when they go for the final
crushing blow against freedom right
because they don't want the the majority
of people that still believe it exists
to find out that it doesn't exist
anymore because they'll be like oh no no
no no no and so what they do is holy but
surely it's it's just it's a story I've
told about eBay how they changed from
yellow to white exactly everybody got
really angry so then what they did was
every day they
one more shade closer to white and the
background over one year turned from
yellow to white without anyone realizing
it cuz it was so slow and gradual that's
what they need to be careful of you know
so when n beat when Google banned the
federalists the other day so basically
Phil's aren't familiar NBC News
contacted Google and said look at these
offensive articles from the Federalist
Google then issued a statement to them
saying we have banned the Federalists a
mainstream conservative website you know
that was a red line and all of a sudden
the entire Internet was lighting up it
was crazy
Trump jr. was like we love men they've
got to make for some and testify and
then Google immediately backtracked no
no no we didn't we knew we know no we
just were talking about their comments
and they're not banned they're rectify
the situation so Google wanted to do it
and they realized they went a little too
hard causing a backlash yeah so did four
shades too too soon right yeah right now
Facebook has a new version which you've
seen the new Facebook I can't stand it
it's awful it's awful but they know that
if they do it all at once
every single user will screech yeah and
then they'll have a problem so what they
do is they do pockets they actually
changed Facebook for me and then a week
later changed it back really yeah I
think I know why I stopped using it I
mean I barely use Facebook once though
once it changed it was just awful and
I'm like I stopped I stopped using it
not on purpose just because I wasn't
communed anymore anymore and then one
day I came back and was normal you know
then I was like whoa so I wonder if they
thought the same thing hoops too far too
much too much better calm down better
slow down so that's what we're seeing
right now with free speech you know
YouTube Twitter like they I think they
want to ban all of this stuff and the
reason they haven't banned me yet from
YouTube is because they don't want
people freaking out just yet that's true
so I don't know man if Trump wins
re-election will they finally just be
like okay well wait another four years
and try and win it's crazy to me that
they're willing to blow everything up to
try and stop Trump from another four
years when they could just wait four
years and then run their candidate and
try and win when Trump can't run for
reelection hmm good point they're insane
so yeah I do think that it's only a
matter of time look if they're good if
these companies are gonna fire the the
family members of people involved in
these stories yeah I think we're well
past the point where speed
is an issue I think to them they're like
Tim Poole is acceptable he's a he's the
like I was saying the negative 2 to
positive 10 yeah yet simples a zero for
the most part may be a positive one cuz
he rags in the Democrats so much but
it's nowhere near conservative like
these other people yeah like when it
went when I was on Crowder's show yeah
the other day like Crowder's much more
opinionated in forceful on his totally
owes yeah not like I'm not as I already
D Montez him didn't they I think I think
he still do monetize for sure I don't
you know his you know going out this
business but they do monetize a ton of
other people you know we saw Luke and an
Ariel get stripped from the partner
program true so they're getting rid of
their undesirables but they need to keep
a few people otherwise everyone would
screech and panic and then what they
want to avoid is being hauled into the
Senate hearings you know to testify
although it doesn't do anything alright
so they're like they know there's a line
for years we have seen them continually
push the line everything's getting worse
but it's never gotten so bad that they
haul in these tech companies until they
went after the federal list and that was
a big mistake you know they took a one
step too far and now they may actually
get hauled in a testify and now no the
DOJ has released guidelines recently on
what they have to do what what they
should do and how bill should be drafted
a to prevent censorship I hope so I feel
like somebody was watching my video
because one of the changes is that they
would define objectionable content as
unlawful so what I've been saying about
section 230 which shields these big tech
companies from liability is that they
should make it so that big tech
companies so long as they only remove
content that's unlawful then they're
there they're not liable for what it
said if they start removing you know
political opinions they should not be
protected like Facebook is literally
publishing editorials yeah so when I
logged into Facebook today I got a big
thing about the importance of black
lives matter I saw that that's a
publisher mm-hm and so if the New York
Times sue them for what they publish now
you can still argue we're in a comment
section so they still still could be
protected but they should be placed in a
different you know bracket Facebook
actually argued legally that they are
both a publisher and a platform before
and people don't realize that New York
Times is a publisher but their comment
section are not liable for that section
230 so even so if Facebook and Instagram
published off and they do like if you go
to the search tab of Instagram you will
get a black lives matter taking up you
know thirty forty percent of your screen
that doesn't matter because the rest of
the content is you know it's uh comments
it's user generated section yeah so
they're gonna get away with it and maybe
the DOJ changes will come through I
really don't think so
the Republicans have has any Republican
come up and and soon the floor yelling
about this the destruction of Thomas
Jefferson and George Washington I don't
know in as the Democrats called to
remove Jefferson from the city council
chamber has any politician said this is
outrageous that they would try and
remove one of our one of our presidents
no idea think about how insane that is
but the first thing I heard from France
is what you just told me nope yeah when
I get rid of anything yeah good luck
trying
Wow no come France said that yeah it's
like she's eating surrender monkeys
that's probably hate speech to be honest
know that that's a joke from I think
Simpsons Simpsons joke that's the funny
thing about where we're at right now is
I always wonder why it is that Teresa
Nielson will be you know this artist
will be canceled because she followed
somebody but Seth MacFarlane is like
heralded as this great right you know
that lift liberal it's like the dude
still makes racist jokes all the time
all episode of family I mean dude Family
Guy and American Dad yeah American dads
premise is very much like the US war in
the Middle East right and it was
supposed to be like making fun of the
neocon family I guess well it's okay if
you're over in the left area because
Seth MacFarlane is very much on the left
you know
I follow him he's outspoken yep and he
does call out sjw's you know he does
Family Guy's got numerous jokes ragging
on canceled culture yeah but he I feel
like he doesn't do enough it's it's it's
a and any avoid probably cuz you like to
be in wretchedness
stick his neck out yeah maybe that's one
of the curses of American individualism
there's no community bond anymore
absolutely true you know there's no
community there they just toppled George
Washington Jefferson and we're any of
these people to be alike stop that I'll
say it a million times yeah you know but
comedians I'd be willing to bet Joe
Rogan would call it crazy oh yeah
probably has yeah I wonder about Dave
Chappelle though I wonder about you know
these bigger media companies definitely
won't think about how insane that is
Jimmy Kimmel right you won't say
anything no these things get canceled
Colbert won't say anything come after
him John Oliver won't say anything
yep they're rich they're rich and their
jokes must be in line with what the
outraged mob demands and they'll cave in
two seconds yeah so now you can have in
the United some Erika the flag being
burned is one thing but people throwing
ropes over statutes and destroying them
is like wow we'll really at this point
yes and then you see what happened in
New Mexico and that guy shows up with a
gun don't destroy our statues and they
attack him yeah they threatened his life
they beat him he shoots the guy several
times they drop the charges
yep he may get charged again but it
looks like the dudes holding a knife
yeah so I'll tell you man it's were we
had the guys in South Philly it's only a
matter of time before Americans say the
law isn't you know what I wouldn't be
surprised if the police get abolish you
know why why why is it that South Philly
residents had to defend that statue and
the police didn't do it what are the
police for if they know they're coming
to destroy public property the cops are
like would you two stand back
the police aren't being protected right
now they're being blamed if you ask
anybody the no no it's their fault in
the started this and it's like they so
all cops every single one wants to wants
to kill any minority it's like come on
I'm talking about that is not the truth
but statues you'd think the cops could
stand around a statue and stop it from
being toppled right they're not even
trying they're pleasantly ordered to
stand down
they're probably ordered to not go
exactly so the issue then is mm-hmm
why would conservative support the
police they're enforcing
unconstitutional orders
the lockdown refusing to protect protect
public property and isn't it all in
democratic cities so they're mostly yeah
down the chain of command
you got the mayor who's like you're not
going I'm gonna call the police chief
you guys are not going or you're gone
I'm gonna out you're gone if you don't
follow what I'm saying right now and
it's like quit then they are they are
quitting they are the democratic cities
yeah I need motional of this Oh
surrounding jurisdictions of Atlanta
I've tried posting don't call us no no
no no no no why they are posting job
openings oh really Wow it's like hey you
need a job here like yeah yeah the
surrounding suburbs and towns were like
will take you yeah they were fine Wow
yeah dude well here's what I think is
gonna happen these activists are
announcing they're gonna do it and they
show up and the cops don't do anything
about it
for whatever reason so how long until we
get a bunch of armed guys like
paramilitary or militia standing guard
and guarding monuments and statues I
can't I can't believe that we haven't
seen it yet you you want a conversation
about these dudes somewhat you don't
have a conversation with these dudes in
South Philly with Christopher Columbus I
kind of roll my eyes I'm like I'm not a
Columbus fan no he's great he's not a
founding father well I agree America and
the colonies are is not the same thing
as what the founding fathers represented
the the colonies were were European
colonial you know it adventurism and
things like this you know the the
founding fathers was an ideological
shift about the equal rights of the
individuals the rights to
self-governance and it was a change away
from the like dare I say to use the
language of these people
the founding fathers opposed the
colonial mindset in a sense they wanted
people to be free and have their own
space and mind their own business
good point Gadsden flag is literally
don't tread on me you know not to be
fair we still had a bunch of you know
lands being seized by the Americans it's
not like these work you know you know
people didn't have their hypocrisy about
them but was an ideological shift so
that what happened before people at
Christopher Columbus and these other you
know conquistadors and preachers before
the colonies was a very very different
mindset and mind you
one hundred hundreds of years hundreds
hundreds of years 1492 Christopher
Columbus to 1776 it's like as a long
time man the big difference as a
seriously big difference but anyway
here's the point when I see people
defending Christopher Columbus for all
his faults and he did not create this
country I think that's very very
interesting now they're toppling
Jefferson in Washington in if these
people came out to Philly
I'd imagine and tried to go after icons
of you know independence yeah I'd
imagine you might see some dead people I
I'm I'm that's what I said
weeks ago I'm not worried I know I'm
worried about it because they're gonna
finally meet Americans that are like no
you're not you're not you're not
shredding on me so what happens then
when we watch the politicians destroy
our monuments in our own City Hall in I
don't live in New York anymore but well
New York is a is a mess a democratic
City run by Democrats are there Patriots
in new Blasio as a joke he is a joke
well Nancy Pelosi is having them take
all the pictures of slave owners out of
the historical Hall no you're
technically correct she's having removed
pictures of Democrats yeah I know I know
that I was gonna throw that out next but
I mean they're all slave owners and
they're going yeah they were all
Democrats yeah so that's the joke she's
like Confederate pictures must be
removed and then the Republicans were
like so you're moving the Democrats and
they are newsflash
Democrats aggregated but to be fair the
actual Democratic voters agree with it
like when someone pointed out that I saw
this post on Twitter is a big threat
about it somebody posted ha ha so there
are moving pics of Democrats the
progressive Democrats were like yes
they'd they're admitting the mistakes
and they're getting rid of it good for
them and I'm like ok you know I mean so
it's like it's funny they're Democrats
getting rid of it
I like the meme of you you know the
video of them taking down and then they
show like the picture of the whole old
white dude and whatever and it's Nancy
Pelosi space I was like oh that's good
it's a good meme yeah it's really
scaring her away I'm like yes thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you